So far we've seen success with loading image data. But it would be great if we
could extend this functionality into loading JavaScript files too. The good
news is that you can add a JavaScript file to the DOM dynamically and just like
with images, you get a callback function, once the file has been loaded. So,
what you need to do now, is to fill in the rest of this code, to allow the load
assets function to take a list of file names, which might be images, or
JavaScript, and load them correctly. Which means is that in here, before we
actually issue off our command, we need to figure out what type of file we're
trying to load. Tricky, tricky. You may have to look at the file name's
extension, to determine this.